as fires raged last night a baby had to
be thrown to safety from a burning
building it was dropped into the arms of
rescuers below
our south africa correspondent john
sparks is in durban
where food warehouses are being raided
and roads are completely gridlocked
in multiple locations in durban there is
mass looting rioting mass unrest as well
we are in a place called mobeni it's
down by the port and durban
we're just going to give you a look at
what is going on right now
what has happened is essentially several
food warehouses and a rice depot have
been invaded they have been and
ransacked
and we've got people basically carting
off what is
inside those facilities it's happening
right now
and in many cases people have brought
cars and trucks to go and fill up their
vehicles
with what they are able to to carry out
of these facilities it's absolute chaos
here absolute
absolute chaos the the police and the
army the
government says it's put 2500 troops on
the streets
the army is nowhere to be seen i mean
this is
really out of control i mean there is no
law
and order no semblance of law and order
here
people are are helping themselves it has
to be said
and we were in another location where
there was
widespread looting going on on nandy
driver
an industrial estate and people said hey
look we're we're hungry
you know we're hungry we haven't eaten
we haven't had anything in three months
and it is true that the the restrictions
put in place because of the global
pandemic have hurt people here a lot of
people have
have lost jobs a lot of people work in
the informal
economy it's very much a hand-to-mouth
existence millions of people in this
country live that way
but what we have here is is really
something quite extraordinary people
have
essentially broken in to food warehouses
and they are stripping them they're
empty
emptying them and if we just go down to
the side here that's my
cameraman garbage lucky to take a shot
you can see people carrying all sorts of
things
away with them boxes of sardines we've
seen mattresses
kitchen appliances i cannot see how long
salava could continue like this it just
you know this is just not this is not
going to work
in the short term law and order is
essentially broken down
and people are helping themselves and
again you know people have reasons for
it
these these disturbances started with
the arrest of
jacob zuma who is from this province
from kazulu natal
he was sanctioned by the constitutional
court they gave him a 15-month
sentence when he failed to participate
in an anti-corruption commission
which he himself initiated when he was
president he then
refused to turn up to the commission
eventually was given a 15-month
sentence and eventually complied with
the order that kicked off some protests
particularly here in kwazulu-natal but
this has really transcended
those protests they have acted the view
of many people anyway as an excuse to
to steal and to plunder
and you know i mean i think i should say
you know this is a country where a lot
of people live
on the edge they really do live on the
edge it's very much a hand to mouth
existence for millions and
millions of people in this country and
what the events over you know the last
week have proved is that
it doesn't take much to tip things over
the edge and
the police are nowhere to be seen the
army i don't know where they are we
haven't seen them we've been in
durban since this morning i haven't seen
a single soldier and
it's very very difficult for them to to
police this they are completely
overwhelmed
yes the government is going to have to
initiate some sort of state of emergency
because this is clearly
out of control i mean there is no sense
of self restraint here there is no
respect
for the for law and order and again your
people have reasons
for that when you ask them this
will justify what they're doing but
at the moment i mean this is a terrible
advertisement
for south africa because it looks
completely out of control